i have experience designing and  implementing secure infrastructure on  google cloud but i need to prove that i  am a security engineer i wonder what my  options are well have you considered the  professional cloud security engineer  certification it's a great way to show  off your cloud security skills on the  resume  tell me more i'm curious  okay so this exam assesses your ability  to secure your cloud infrastructure and  your applications such as configuring  access within your infrastructure  network security data protection and  more security things like that that's  really comprehensive i love it you got  this  oh wait before i let you go any advice  on where to start there are tons of  training resources and sample questions  hands-on labs some demand courses just  check them out  [Music]